meantime the British government has it
done enough to evacuate people from
Sudan let's speak in more detail should
we too um and ask him done a biomedical
scientist and uh at the Civil Service I
think I'm saying is that is that the
correct title thank you for joining us
uh tell me about your situation with
your wife so my personal situation my
wife
um we got married in 2021
and
um
I was in the process of actually
completing the spouse family visa and
obviously now once once the war broke
out there is no way to complete this
there is no way for her to do biometric
tests the TLC is closed the British um
Embassy is closed so there's absolutely
no information from the government of
what
people in my situation can do and what
they need to do in order for them to
actually get them out into US Safety
have you been able to communicate with
your wife at the moment there have some
being some communication but we had also
some issues with the power
um I mean the landlines and internet so
they took out the internet about a
couple of days ago and I was very a
stressful situation for many Sudanese
people and people in my shoes to be able
to contact their families
um you don't you don't really know
what's happening you know what the
conditions are like there the conditions
are really really bad so people there's
no water there's no electricity
um there Food Supplies are running low
I've been able to go outside
um sorry unable to go outside yeah
unable to go outside so you can't even
go outside to buy this basic necessities
or or basic supplies the banks are
closed so people can't even withdraw
money to take money to actually buy
these supplies
um there's literally people are just
sitting ducks waiting for their fate
um and your wife is not allowed to come
here because she doesn't have the name
she can't yeah she can't she she's not
allowed to so the government recently
released
um a statement saying if you are in
Sudan and you're a British national uh
you can take your immediate family with
you but they have to have the necessary
Visa approvals so what or what of people
so what does that leave you exactly just
somewhere in lingo and wondering what um
The Next Step this government is going
to do and why haven't they actually even
brought in uh supplies uh when the all
of these countries are evacuating so
bring the supplies in with the planes
with the planes yeah it supplies medical
water all the basic human humanitarian
AIDs that people actually really in
desperate need would you want to say to
the British government I think they need
to do more they need to act rapidly and
need to be more quicker responsive
responding and they need to actually
focus and take this matter seriously
because I feel like they're not really
taking that seriously as other EU
countries they they were quicker to
respond to this situation to evacuate
some of their people their homes
actually wouldn't buy into that when I
was putting that to her I don't know if
you saw
um I was saying that the Germans were
critical of the British not directly but
implicitly
um saying that they they were bringing
out Brits because
um the British government was not or
hadn't acted at that stage and the pro
and the Home Secretary said it wasn't a
competition
is is not a competition but it's a
humanitarian issue and the British
government has a responsibility like
every other government to to look after
the British Nationals who are stuck in
Sudan and a lot of them are stuck in
Khartoum and some of them are actually
outside of cartwheel how do you connect
to these people outside of cartoon they
know they don't even have internet
access to be able to register they're
telling people to register online
um how are you going to be able to
register online if there's no internet
there's blackout what what how are these
people going to be you know tracked or
um is I think they need to do a bit more
they need to they need to stop making
excuses and actually act like every
other country is acting okay finally
when do you think you'll see your wife
again I have absolutely no idea I have
no idea I'm just um just keep reading
online seeing news you know what's
happening just try to see if there's any
updates
um if there's rules for her to be taken
out to um in a safe country right now
there's no countries actually opening
their borders what do you keep in touch
with us and let us know how you get on
thank you very much thank you so much I
really appreciate you taking the time